guys it's early in some country I'm Greg
Alba I'm John Humphrey
I'm Andrew Gordon why do we need women
in a trailer reaction for Black Widow
when we got three do to support women
there we go justify you saying you don't
identify as a woman Greg I stopped just
as a yesterday and you're wearing
Edith glasses I'm wearing my daredevil
beanie because Black Widow had a romance
with daredevil listening midnight guys
John stressed like a Russian let's get
into this Andrew you were in a super man
we don't have time for this Andrew came
over here last minute hey guys we're so
close to 700 K why do you subscribe and
click that note up let's film
did she say that line in Avengers
[Music]
but that th William Hurt they have Ross
Yelena Oh
[Music]
Jason Bourne eat your heart out damn the
real John looking sis probably trained
group together nice like now I get a
Mission Impossible bug
Wow whoa that's white soon Jazzmaster
racially I'm in yeah right the red
Guardian Russian Captain America that's
what happened
oh so excited for it oh wow dams like
out of Avengers a day yeah oh the Red
Room baby she call it the Redrum
may 20 2014
good not be a good movie but from what
we're getting right now this looks like
a solid spy action thriller of course
they're teasing of learning more about
her roots there it's a lot of the
dialogue overlapping in this trailer
welcome home
sis family done running with my
underwear away from my past and it looks
like you're going to explore some of
those like KGB operative routes the
Hanahan action does look great does look
a lot like John wick style kind of
fighting or atomic blonde you know that
director he wanted it to be on the way
it's choreographed adjust the way shot
as well what is really got me excited
for is actually the whole supporting
cast
David Harbor as the rain garden oh boy
Hellboy hopper David Hartman David
Harbor geek David Guardian and Muslim
ahartry getting to do this really looks
like he's having a total blast looks
hilarious and it florence pew i i feel
like it's gonna be a toss-up between
who's gonna be a scene stealer in
florence pew and then david Harbor I
feel idea harbors gonna be the more
bombastic or Gary is kind of performant
in the comic relief yeah band and other
people I've been talking a bit about how
Flora's pews yalena will be potentially
a handoff to character for Black Widow
even the taskmaster character looks
great too like everything about this
looks pretty solid
other than the feather got really big in
the end but it still felt for the most
part already grounded and what it wanted
to do and there's been a big debate in
the zeitgeist of like should Marvel
really kick off their face for with a
prequel to Black Widow is like this is
coming a little too late this trailer
did a good job on making me not care at
all about that
like I was like I still want to see this
looks pretty awesome you know watching
this trailer
to me a budapest all over again you know
remember that just like Budapest oh I
guess we remember Budapest Budapest is a
fictional country the marvel cinematic I
guess we're I guess we remembered
because a little but it's so great that
Marta that Marvel is finally giving us
the first female comic book film I'm not
counting Supergirl engineer bar I'm that
kind Catwoman I'm not counting Electra
I'm that kind Captain Marvel I'm not
counting Wonder Woman those were named
in movies right I'm just gonna it's not
the first one but it's really cool that
we do like I get it now you do get it
you're on it no but kind of like heart
beyond what Greg said I like seeing the
flaws in black well like I still like
seeing how terrible I like seeing like
you know because when she's with the
Avengers yeah we've had a couple scenes
like in Avengers age of Ultron when you
know scarlet bow which did the whole
thing like we saw like you know kind of
a little bit deep into her past you know
internship with the Red Room and all
that but I like that this film is really
gonna explore the character a lot more
cuz when she's with the Avengers like no
offense she's great like the characters
great Scarlett's great but she's got a
little bit overshadowed by some of the
other characters and naturally so it's a
team film like I like that we're getting
to explore the character and seeing like
roots of her past like that's that's
what's interesting to me I like some of
the callbacks so I think she said
nothing lasts forever and remember that
and I know I said kind of during the
trailer but I think they were just
taking lines directly but they were but
I feel like that particular one I
thought I might have said but you guys
will correct me in the comments ever let
me know how a bunch of a dumb ass I am
but I like some of the callbacks too and
that one shot where she's flying through
the sky kind of reminded me a little bit
of everyone's favorite film spider-man 3
with Tobey Maguire where he's flying
down like missing all the debris trying
to catch gwen stacy so obviously this
isn't the sky that's up a building but
really cool action scenes in the hand
and combat looks awesome and David Arbor
looks great yeah yeah your turn John hi
John be honest buddy no I mean that's my
favorite thing about this trailer is
kind of what you said that I'm not
really so concerned with all the
periphery stuff as much as I was just
gripped by the general direction this
movie seems to be headed in I like the
idea that Marvel is gonna throw down on
some more of that like like Winter
Soldier I think everybody kind of agrees
had some really notable
I think to go back to that but in a
different scope in a more Jason Bourne
or Mission Impossible like the thing is
this movie trailer really reminded me of
those two movies especially with the way
you have like the aerial stunts at the
end yeah stuff like that and you also
have a team so there are certain
elements that feel like they're very of
them now and I'm hoping that this movie
can just make it its own and what I do
appreciate is from like the vague amount
of research I think we all did
I like that from looking at them so I
like different looking into this trailer
I have a bunch of characters who I know
can go either way morally and I don't
know where they're all gonna fall based
on this and so it looks like it's gonna
be Rachel Weisz is a bad guy I think
it's a quite misleading out the trailer
because they did it really hone in on
her and I feel like a lot of people make
including Iron Maiden but they're there
all the dinner-table we're all family
but she are you gonna sass Toria Slee
anti ya Widow kinda cool I also feel
like y'all ain't I wouldn't be shocked
if Yelena like betrays them too and like
maybe that's her arc is like she's like
seeing like the root of her problems and
like now she has to grow the mantle of
becoming the Black Widow one day but
like maybe she's working with tasmat I
don't know I think Yelena and Black
Widow the natasha are gonna have like
the whole sister versus sister debate
that's gonna be their character arc and
then taskmasters is gonna be Iron
Maiden's Bane oh yeah I got a line no I
mean again I don't know exactly I'm sure
everyone in the comment section will
tell us exactly when this takes place in
the timeline and obviously we'll find
out we see the film I mean between civil
okay it takes place right before that
star seriously but seriously what did we
think of star wars the last VPS let me
tell you release the Snyder guy yeah no
but seriously though politics and why my
watch man I really want to see the
Winter Soldier in this I know it's
probably not gonna happen but ever since
Natasha explained in Captain America the
Winter Soldier they but they flop this
trailer in winter it's an easter egg
he's gonna be in yeah but having like
having that Russian slug we should talk
about then I wouldn't be shocked if we
get to see Robert Downey jr. and this as
well as confirmed
was correct already what you guys
honestly though what you guys think of
the CG the DA general runs it terrible
great it's as good as Princess Leia in
rogue one what it's pretty bad I wish
they had more shots that the aging was
bad on that but I also really thought
the music was awesome now you see if
they were smart they would have made
William Hurt look like how he did in
Dark City like go for that 1998 look but
but Marvel is the furthest thing from
smart their movies don't make that much
money no how many the Avengers end game
didn't make that much right no they're
still struggling to make back the budget
alright guys well are you excited for
this Black Widow movie do you think this
is the best way to start off phase four
who do you think will be the highlight
from this film comment below
YouTube engagement questions you guys
can subscribe to the reel rejects click
that notification bell follow Andrew
somewhere on social media maybe even his
youtube channel might be doing
impressions here on the reel rejects
apparently there's one right Patrick
Swayze is right ghost
hatred a shout out to a man named JN
Valente our great friend who has been
one of our most loyal patrons for the
longest time I'm sorry I did not shout
you out last month when we owed you a
shout out do I blame John you should
mostly but that little sliver where I
blame myself for not giving you a
shout-out I don't really feel that all
the blame goes to this Russian right
here and the reason we don't here for
him is because he's at the Red Room
right now training to have me killed by
him for not getting
shout out this is my just desserts what
the hell is the Red Room
what is he talking okay they coat the
Red Room I they should have called it
Red Rum right that sounds more that
sounds better
no Red Rum Easter Egg is gone all oh I
was trying to act dumb you made it about
The Shining John's got insecure shouts
Patrick Swayze